Hola Muy Bienvenidos a esta nueva
emisión de la entrevista de Franz 24 en
español nos acompaña en esta oportunidad
selin custom ella es exploradora
defensora ambiental y cineasta y no solo
eso también es diseñadora de joyas
autora presentadora de podcast y
podríamos continuar muchísimo más se les
gustó Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de Frank 24
con mucho gusto estar aquí con ustedes
Gracias una vez más a usted selim bueno
es inevitable hablar contigo y no hacer
referencia a su abuelo verdad porque
hablamos del legendario explorador Jack
costó viajó usted con él estuvo de hecho
en su boca de investigación calipso no
icónico no solo con él también con su
abuela que tuvo un rol clave en las
historias que conocemos Qué recuerdos
tiene Y cómo la marcó la labor de su
abuelo y también por supuesto de su
abuela que si bien no fue la famosa tuvo
un rol clave no en las historias que
conocemos
la mayoría de las personas conocen la
historia de mi abuelo Porque él fue como
la cima del iceberg que todos hablaron
de él que él estaba enfrente de las
cámaras pero realmente es todo un
trabajo de un equipo de personas detrás
de las cámaras y también en expediciones
lo que yo viví a través de Esto fue todo
una historia de una comunidad de
personas que querían bueno ir a explorar
a entender pero también a llevar a
historias alrededor del mundo lo lindo
para mí era que las mujeres de mi
familia también estaban involucradas y
como había dicho mi abuela estaba muy
con mi abuelo en todos los viajes aún
más que él más que cualquier otro hombre
de la expedición mi abuela estaba allí
desde el inicio hasta hasta el final de
la expedición y mi mamá era fotógrafa
durante 13 años también viajaba tres
meses por año en decisiones Así que eso
para mí era como normal en mi familia
bueno como lo dijimos no fue un gran
divulgador gracias a sus trabajos su
documentales a bordo del calipso como
decíamos muchísima gente alrededor de
todo el mundo pudo conocer las
profundidades de mundo submarino verdad
y de algún modo usted está continuando
con esa línea no por eso quisiera que
habláramos de su documental drives On
The Edge no en el cual acompañó a
pueblos originarios del Valle del
yabarino en la amazonía brasileña
cuéntenos Cómo nació este proyecto y Con
qué se encontró a lo largo de todo ese
trabajo
Pues yo fui por primera vez al amazonas
cuando tenía nueve años y en este
momento tuve una conexión digamos
profunda con este ecosistema en 2006 y
siete hice un documental con mi papá que
me hizo conocer a las personas a los
indígenas de la tierra del marido sabary
que me pidieron de regresar y contar su
historia al mundo porque ellos estaban
desapareciendo porque la gente estaba
llegando de manera ilegal para buscar
oro para buscar
madera para cazar para pescar y estaban
desapareciendo esas personas y querían
vivir más que sobrevivir Así que regresé
y hice ese documental
que pasé siete años haciéndolo para
realmente dar un espacio para que lo
escuchamos porque realmente esas
personas tienen una voz tienen una voz
muy clara quieren vivir y los problemas
que ellos por ejemplo todo la invasión
ilegal viene de afuera las enfermedades
también fueron de afuera no son de ellos
por lo tanto quieren vivir la vida como
la quieren vivir ellos pero necesitan
nuestro apoyo para seguir apoyando
protegiendo este territorio y
protegiendo sus derechos lo que es súper
importante saber Es que donde hay
pueblos indígenas hay menos
deforestación
que dentro de lugares que son
preservados solamente por el medio
ambiente o sea es decir que la presencia
de los indígenas solo esto como
Guardianes de estos ecosistemas nos da
la posibilidad de proteger aún más esos
ecosistemas de lo cual dependemos
nosotros lo que se desprende aquí es que
es clave para para proteger los
territorios Como por ejemplo la amazonía
no que es clave para todo el mundo hace
falta proteger a quienes los defienden a
esos territorios no a sus Guardianes
precisa
O sea hay un hecho que fue súper
importante para mí es que los pueblos
indígenas son
entre 4 y 5% de la población mundial
pero en su territorios protegen 80% de
la biodiversidad y eso ya sabemos que
para proteger nuestro futuro tenemos que
proteger la biodiversidad si ya si ya
entendemos esto podemos ver que la
protección de los indígenas va mano en
mano en la protección del medio ambiente
y ya sabemos que el cambio climático es
algo que ya todo lo estamos entendiendo
y lo vamos a sufrir así que tenemos que
ver que que en proteger sus derechos
También estamos protegiendo a nuestro
futuro absolutamente hablemos el link de
los desafíos medioambientales y algo muy
interesante que usted plantea Porque
además por supuesto de muchísimas
cuestiones que afectan al medio ambiente
no hablamos de los niveles de
contaminación
emisiones de gases millones de bosques
muchísimos otros hechos que ya estamos
viendo no algunos Lamentablemente
irreversibles usted ha dicho que el
desafío más grande es la conciencia del
ser humano en este sentido explorar no
solo al medio ambiente sino también las
miradas no de los seres humanos sobre el
medio ambiente como la caracterizarías Y
cómo crees que debería ser esa mirada y
esa convivencia Perdón también
importante que yo pasé tantos años
viajando el mundo viéndolo lo que hay
afuera regresando con lindas historias o
historias tristes pero realmente Bueno
al inicio mis estudios fueron en
psicología porque quería entender porque
hacemos Por quÉ actuamos como actuamos
como cambiamos y los años que han pasado
ahora me estoy dando cuenta con el
tiempo que casi se frenó porque no viaje
mucho como muchos Yo me di cuenta que
realmente tenemos que regresar a esa
idea que la confiesan del ser humano es
donde empieza todo
si nosotros no estamos conectados con la
naturaleza si no sabemos De dónde viene
nuestra comida Claro que quizás no vamos
a pensar que estamos conectados con el
Amazonas porque nos parece tan lejos
quizás los océanos nos parecen tan
grandes que qué importa si pescamos pero
si realmente entendemos De dónde viene
la comida por qué respiramos Porque es
interesante y importante entender otras
culturas vamos a entender que ese cambio
de conciencia es una conexión con todo
lo que pasa en el mundo Pero esto
realmente creo que tiene que empezar con
entenderse a sí mismo Buscar porque
somos como somos nosotros Porque
pensamos como pensamos de dónde vienen
nuestras creencias quizás pasar un
momento en realmente empezar a sanarnos
nosotros Desde adentro para entender Por
qué actuamos Como actuamos creo que si
una vez empezamos a sanar yo mismo vamos
a ver que lo mejor somos para nosotros
lo mejor vamos a estar para los demás lo
mejor vamos a cuidar el medio ambiente
Así que mi exploración ahora va más
hacia adentro para proteger mejor el
medio ambiente ese complemento no entre
la exploración interna tan necesaria
para luego pasar a explorar el mundo
verdad Selina ahora quisiera hablar de
un actor que se ha transformado con un
actor que se ha transformado En clave no
en lo que es la lucha contra el cambio
climático y a favor del medio ambiente
que son los jóvenes están en las calles
de todo el mundo y a la cabeza del
movimiento ambientalista colocaron el
tema en la agenda mundial de una manera
muy fuerte porque cree que son ellos
justamente quienes están liderando este
activismo
Bueno creo que ahora lo que está pasando
es con todo la el acceso a los medias
que tiene los jóvenes Siempre han tenido
una voz pero no les estaba quizás no
estuvimos escuchando tal como no
estuvimos escuchando a los Indígenas
ahora los jóvenes tienen acceso a
información y ellos están Sabiendo lo
que está pasando en el mundo creo que
nacimos con un entendimiento de esta
conexión con todo lo que pasa y los
jóvenes ahora tienen una voz muy fuerte
y y nuestra responsabilidad como adultos
es darle un espacio para proteger para
Perdón hablar de todo esto pero
apoyarles no es su responsabilidad de
cuidar todo No es su responsabilidad de
encontrar soluciones a los problemas que
empezamos nosotros pero sí realmente
creo que hay un movimiento
intergeneracional que es súper
interesante en este momento que para mí
me mueve mucho como me da mucha
esperanza de lo que vamos a ver en el
futuro si nos juntamos con ellos de los
ancianos de nuestra generación y los
jóvenes para trabajar juntos una
articulación clave Sin lugar a dudas
Bueno hablamos usted también de
soluciones recién hoy precisamente acaba
de finalizar la cop 27 no que se llevó a
cabo en Egipto hablamos de la Cumbre de
medioambiental de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas Cuál es su postura sobre
este tipo de eventos de encuentros y los
compromisos que salen del no porque es
objeto de muchas críticas no y muchas se
apuntan a la necesidad de pasar de los
papeles a las acciones concretas verdad
Bueno pasar del papel a la acción lo
estuvimos diciendo desde
ya desde tres generaciones lo estamos
hablando de esa necesidad creo que la
dificultad es que cuando uno piensa que
el otro va a ganar algo y nosotros vamos
a perder no vamos a ver que realmente
estamos en ese planeta juntos Yo no soy
mucho de hablar de política porque no no
es mi meta de hacer las cosas
las reuniones como caps son necesarias
no me sorprende que fue muy frustrante
porque cada vez Decimos lo mismo yo no
voy a esas conferencias porque prefiero
ir donde la gente quizás no estaban
antes pensando en el medio ambiente Por
ejemplo yo estaba en Río la otra semana
hablando con personas que están en
innovación y tecnología Tenemos que
hablar entre sectores no solamente en
los mismos intereses porque las empresas
tienen que cambiar ya la mentalidad
digamos del
ciudadano en francés del individual está
cambiando mucho y estamos poniendo
presión lo que me llama mucho la
atención es que y eso fue un glaciólogo
que me lo dijo Dani Thompson y él me
dijo lástimamente el problema es que los
seres humanos no actúan hasta que su
espalda está contra la pared pero con el
cambio climático Ya es demasiado tarde
tenemos que darnos cuenta y eso siempre
regreso a la sabiduría de los indígenas
que empiezan en siete generaciones si
realmente todos nosotros lo hacemos así
pensamos mucho más en adelante que sus
hijos y sus nietos vamos a hacer la
buena cosa pero si siempre hay intereses
políticos o económicos nos enredamos en
cosas que realmente no es sobrevivencia
del ser humano de verdad
Lamentablemente Se nos acabó el tiempo
se pasó rapidísimo Le agradezco
muchísimo por esta entrevista y por su
tiempo no a ustedes Muchísimas gracias
una vez más y a nuestra audiencia como
siempre la invitamos a que sigan
informados en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
transmity 4.com sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]